rien de tout cela n'a jamais été tenté
avant de piloter un hélicoptère demande beaucoup
de talent pour mettre quelqu'un comme Tom dans une
situation comme celle-ci, il est presque impossible
d'imaginer qu'il est venu me voir et il a dit
que nous allions à Airbus et nous allons
apprendre à piloter un hélicoptère et être à
2 000 notre pilote en très peu
de temps prendre quelque chose comme trois mois
de journées de huit heures juste pour devenir un
pilote d'hélicoptère novice Tom devait
travailler 24 heures sur 24 pour atteindre le niveau
de compétence le  la séquence signifie qu'il y a
très peu d'étudiants qui ont son niveau de
dévouement et de concentration, merci
presque les poursuites aériennes que vous verrez depuis un
hélicoptère, nous n'activons généralement pas les
caméras, nous avons donc développé ces plates-formes
au cours des deux derniers mois lorsque  nous
pouvons essentiellement monter deux caméras pour
montrer qu'Ethan Hunt pilote l'
hélicoptère sans personne d'autre, chaque
position de caméra a été conçue pour que
vous puissiez voir que tom fait tout
lui-même, c'est super important pour un
film mi  ssion de tout faire
pratiquement pour de vrai Tom ne veut
pas c'est sur l'écran vert que le
public peut dire quand quelque chose a
été trompé pour la sécurité tous les pilotes
se réunissent le matin et ils ont
discuté très clairement où ils
vont être  et quelles sont leurs positions
pour chaque tir et regardez vers le bas et je vais le
prendre au-dessus des cascades j'y entre
tout de suite c'est génial la partie la plus
dangereuse de la séquence de flèches est vraiment
qu'il y a plus d'un hélicoptère dans
les airs nous avons 13 hélicoptères  de la
production, ceux qui sont filmés en train de faire de la
voltige à quelques mètres l'un de l'
autre, c'est assez bien tout au long de la
séquence, le contact visuel
, puis il y a Tom, il est pilote, il
agit et qui est le caméraman,
nous sommes presque prêts lorsque vous ajoutez cette
partie était  la spirale descendante à 360 degrés que la
plupart des planètes ne tenteraient pas est le
virage en tire-bouchon est très difficile pour un
pilote, il faut beaucoup d'habileté beaucoup de
pratique vous faites une erreur quelqu'un
va mourir f  à partir de là, je vais aller à quoi
ressemble chaque spirale il va écraser
ce Pacifique
oh c'est ce que je veux Howard c'est mon
signal très bouleversant ici Chris
manque absolument suma retombées possibles toi cinéma
Lupo muet